[Musik]
seit fast einem Jahr sind wir als
Reporter in den früheren
Sowjetrepubliken unterwegs wir berichten
über Länder die sich von Russland
bedroht fühlen die seit dem Angriff auf
die Ukraine von neuen Herausforderungen
stehen und über Länder die abhängig sind
von Moskau
wie hat sich die Perspektive dieser
starken verändert wohin wenden sie ihren
Blick und wie ist das Leben für
Millionen Menschen im Schatten Russlands
[Applaus]
[Musik]
unsere Reise beginnt an den Grenzen der
EU und führte uns über den konflikthert
Kaukasus bis nach Zentralasien an die
Grenzen Chinas
[Musik]
Moldau ist zerrissen zwischen Russland
und Europa
in dem kleinen Land erleben wir
Konflikte die in der ehemaligen
Sowjetunion wieder aufbrechen seit dem
russischen Einmarsch in die Ukraine
Moldau ist mehr denn je gespalten etwa
die Hälfte der Menschen hier ist für
Europa die andere Hälfte für Russland
Moskau befeuert aktiv die Konflikte im
Land mit russischen Truppen und
Propaganda
besonders drastisch sieht man das auf
dem Land hier Fach der Kreml die Wut der
Menschen an
wir sind in kirtrosso 20 km außerhalb
der Hauptstadt die Temperaturen liegen
zum Zeitpunkt der Dreharbeiten bei 0°
. weil das Gas zu teuer ist heizt die
70-Jährige Galina scalosub wieder mit
Holz
etwa 21 Jahrhundert mitten in Europa
wer ist Ihrer Meinung nach Schulter
daran
das System ist für Galina die Pro
europäische Regierung und die werde
gesteuert vom Westen der NATO den USA
sagt Galina
in Ihrem Wohnzimmer läuft russisches
Staatsfernsehen in Dauerschleife sie ist
der Meinung dass Russland keine Schuld
hat am Krieg in der Ukraine
angucken sondern ist doch
es gibt niemanden außer silensky der
diesen Krieg so sehr möchte er will dass
dieser Krieg sehr lange dauert das sagen
sie in Europa und selbst beiden hat das
gesagt lang lang
auf dem Land denken viele wie Galina
[Musik]
anders sieht es in den Städten aus
dort hat man Angst das Russland sie als
nächstes angreift in Chisinau wollen
viele in die Europäische Union im Mai
demonstrieren hier zehntausende
[Musik]
ich kann nicht akzeptieren was unter
russischer Herrschaft passiert welche
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
verübt werden ich kann die Idee nicht
akzeptieren zurückzugehen zu Russland
unsere Zukunft ist Europa
[Musik]
der Westen will Putin etwas
entgegensetzen im Juni kommen deshalb
fast 50 Staats- und Regierungschefs nach
Moldau die Botschaft wir stehen an der
Seite der proeuropäischen Präsidentin
Maja Sandow
[Musik]
seit Jahrzehnten sind russische Truppen
in Moldau stationiert genauer in der
abtrünnigen Provinz Transnistrien dort
hat Russland die Kontrolle diktiert den
Menschen ihre Meinung ihren Blick auf
den Krieg westliche Presse ist dort
unerwünscht
wie sehr das für die Menschen zu
Zerreißprobe wird sehen wir in doroskaja
an der Grenze zu transistrieren
jeden Tag überqueren mittags mehrere
Busse diesen Checkpoint
hunderte Schüler müssen den Konflikt
West gegen Ost ausbaden
seit vielen Jahren organisiert
Direktorin Eleonora jackafska ja diesen
Schulalltag die moldauischen Schüler
kommen am Vormittag die transistischen
am Nachmittag
der Unterschied dort ist dass die Kinder
feindselig gegen alles erzogen werden
Sie lernen dass sie von Feinden umgeben
sind gegen Europa gegen Amerika gegen
Moldau gegen alles
wem Unterricht frei von russischer
Propaganda wichtig ist schickt seine
Kinder über den Checkpoint viel Aufwand
für freie Bildung
wir brauchen 50 Minuten für nur eine
Strecke und wir überqueren die Grenze
zweimal
das ist lästig wir verschwenden so jeden
Tag Zeit
die transistischen Schüler leben
eigentlich nur zehn Kilometer entfernt
und trotzdem in einer anderen Welt
wir versuchen ihnen beizubringen ihre
Meinung frei zu äußern natürlich im
Rahmen des Gesetzes aber sie dürfen hier
sagen was sie denken weil wir hier alle
freie Menschen sind
in Moldau kämpfen Russland und der
Westen um die Deutungshoheit
gewinnt Moskau die Oberhand droht hier
womöglich der nächste Krieg
[Musik]
Georgien erlebt Russland jeden Tag als
Besatzer
seit dem Kaukasus Krieg 2008 besetzen
russische Truppen 20% des Landes
die Panzer des Kreml stehen damals
wenige Kilometer vor der Hauptstadt
Tiflis
auch deswegen sind viele Georgier an der
Seite der Ukraine
doch dann kommen ausgerechnet 10.000
Russen nach Georgien September 2022
Putin verkündet die Teilmobilmachung
wer nicht an die Front will flieht aus
Russland
für badri eine Katastrophe wir treffen
in kurz nach der Massenflucht er hält
die Russen im Land für eine Gefahr auf
seinem Plakat steht Grüße an alle
russischen Deserteure damit empfängt er
sie am Flughafen von Tiflis
es geht um die Menschen die Putins
Regime eigentlich gut finden die auf der
einen Seite den Krieg und die Repression
gegen die Ukraine unterstützt haben aber
sich dann als ihr Leben in Gefahr war
dazu entschieden haben wegzulaufen und
in Georgien Schutz zu suchen
in einem heruntergekommenen Teil der
Altstadt erleben wir wie viele der
geflüchteten russenhausen in einem
Keller wohnen 14 Männer auf engstem Raum
es ist stickig und es riecht nach dem
Ruß der Kamine
wir treffen Alexander aus Gras nur da
der 35-Jährige wäre wohl eingezogen
worden doch vorher ist er geflohen
ich habe nur eine Tasche mitgenommen und
nicht so viele Sachen ein paar Hemden
und zwei oder drei Paar Schuhe
Alexander fühlt sich nicht willkommen in
Tiflis einmal wurde er auf der Straße
beleidigt weil sein Auto ein russisches
Kennzeichen hat
[Musik]
man spürt die Abneigung gegenüber Russen
die Menschen hier haben Angst dass
irgendwann die russische Armee kommt um
russische Interessen zu schützen wenn zu
viele Russen hier sind
Alexander kann sich nicht vorstellen für
Russland zu kämpfen er gehört zum
Minderheit der Kosaken und zeigt uns die
Flagge seines Volkes
damals sagt er uns dass er nicht mehr
zurück will
doch als wir neun Monate später mit ihm
in Kontakt treten ist er wieder in
Russland er habe keinen Job gefunden
noch einmal mit uns sprechen will er
nicht
wegen der vielen Russen in der Stadt
wird der Wohnraum knapp die Preise
steigen
für diesen Georgier bedeutet das er kann
hier kaum mehr überleben
Georgi ist aus einem Bergdorf nach
Tiflis gezogen um zu studieren seine
Wohnung hat keine Tür und die Toilette
spült er mit einem Eimer
gleich neben dem Herd ist auch die
Dusche das Schlafzimmer teilt er sich
mit seiner Schwester
wir haben sehr viele Besucher aus
anderen Ländern vor allem aus Russland
deswegen haben die Vermieter alle ihre
Preise erhöht
haben es schwer wir können nicht so viel
bezahlen und müssen eine Wohnung finden
die billig und trotzdem gut ist
[Musik]
Georgi und seine Schwester Zahlen
umgerechnet 110 Euro
für die beiden ist das viel Geld
[Musik]
das erkenne bessere Wohnung findet sei
die Schuld der Russen
[Musik]
klar bin ich wütend ich finde erst
sollte man sich um die Georgier kümmern
dann um alle anderen wie die Russen
immer wieder entlädt sich die Wut vieler
Georgia auf Russland das ihnen mit dem
Krieg in der Ukraine so viele Probleme
bereitet auf ihre Regierung die sich
Moskau anbiedert
sie wollen den Einfluss Russlands nicht
mehr sie wollen in die EU
[Musik]
im Juni treffen wir Aktivist wieder vor
dem Parlament den Tiflis mehrmals pro
Woche protestiert er mittlerweile mit
seinen Freunden gegen die Regierung
gegen die Russen und gegen Putin
es sind keine Massen wie noch im
Frühjahr doch sie geben nicht auf
die Mehrheit der Georgier wünscht die
sowjetischen Allianzen endlich
loszuwerden so dass wir unser Ziel
erreichen und unser Ziel ist die
westliche zivilisierte Welt
Moskau hat 70 Jahre lang alles in der
Sowjetunion dominiert Politik Wirtschaft
Militär
Konflikte löste der Kreml auf seine Art
auch nach dem Zusammenbruch der UdSSR
doch Russland ist wegen des Ukraine
kriegsgeschwächt die Konsequenz in
manchen ehemaligen Sowjetrepubliken
brechen ungelöste Konflikte wieder auf
nirgends sieht man das so deutlich wie
in Armenien
[Musik]
die Armenia fühlen sich seit dem Ukraine
Krieg von Russland allein gelassen
Russland das eigentlich immer in ihrer
Seite stand
deshalb trainiert
im vergangenen Herbst fast jeden Abend
hier am Rande der Hauptstadt ihre Bahn
sie haben Angst vor einem ganz anderen
Krieg gegen den Erzfeind Aserbaidschan
jeden Morgen wachen wir auf und haben
Angst dass es eine weitere Eskalation an
der Grenze gab jeden Tag hören wir von
Schießereien an der armenisch
aserbaidschanischen Grenze von
Verwundeten und neuen Opfern
Russland und die anderen Staaten
bezeichnen sich als unsere Verbündeten
aber Armenien kann sich nur auf sich
selbst verlassen
eine militärische Ausbildung hat hier
niemand sie sind freiwillige die
Armeniens Armee unterstützen wollen
falls Aserbaidschan angreift deshalb
haben sie sich dieser paramilitärischen
Miliz angeschlossen
auch Frauen müssen jetzt kämpfen lernen
findet an ihn für das Training an der
Waffe gibt die 25-Jährige ihren kleinen
Sohn in die Hände einer Babysitterin
die ganze Familie im Verteidigungsmodus
denn es ist ein Kampf David gegen Goliat
mit alten sowjetischen Kalaschnikows
gegen eine moderne aserbaidschanische
Armee
noch trainieren Sie mit Attrappen
ich werde zu einer echten Waffe greifen
wenn mein Mann mein Vater mein Bruder
und jene Männer die das gleiche
Wertesystem haben wie ich an die Grenze
gehen
gestern und zwar sobald auch nur ein
Zentimeter unseres Landes unseres
Territoriums meine Heimat dem Feind
überlassen wird
[Musik]
doch wo verlaufen die Grenzen wo hört
armenisches Territorium auf fängt
aserbaidschanisches an
die beiden Völker bekämpfen sich seit
Generationen in der Sowjetunion war
alles ein Land danach bricht der Kampf
um die Grenzen wieder auf die letzten
größeren Gefechte gab es im September im
Süden des Landes
dorthin fahren wir in die Berge wo
aserbaidschanische Bomben auch in den
Dörfern eingeschlagen sind
wir treffen narine die mit ihren drei
Söhnen in jamuk ganz nah an der
aserbaidschanischen Grenze lebt in einer
Nacht im September ändert sich ihr Leben
schlagartig als ein Granatsplitter ihr
Haus trifft
[Musik]
ich hatte große Angst mit einem kleinen
Kind zu Hause
ab dem Moment als das Glas in Scherben
zersprang schlief in meine Kinder nicht
mehr auch die beiden anderen Kinder
hatten große Angst
wie viele Familien verließen auch narine
und ihre Kinder fluchtartig ihr zu Hause
doch sie kamen zurück wie alle hier sie
wissen nicht wo sie sonst hin sollen
diese Orte gehören unstrittig zu
Armenien aber es gibt immer wieder
kleinere Angriffe inzwischen besetzt
Aserbaidschan einige Quadratkilometer
armenischen Territoriums
zurück in der Hauptstadt
hier haben viele genug von Russland das
lange als engster Partner als Schutz
macht Armeniens galt
das kleine Land braucht dringend
mächtige Verbündete am liebsten hätten
sie die USA und Europa an ihrer Seite
[Applaus]
ein Dreivierteljahr später treffen wir
Angie wieder sie hat ihre
Kampfausbildung abgeschlossen macht
jetzt Öffentlichkeitsarbeit für ihre
paramilitärische Einheit
Interviews fortan grün sind Ihr
Tagesgeschäft
zu besprechen gibt es viel vorsichtige
diplomatische Annäherung zwischen
Armenien und Aserbaidschan aber auch
neue Eskalationen
statt mit Kalaschnikow kämpft sie mit
Kamera und Laptop
patrastenmann ich habe mich vorbereitet
damals als sie uns besucht haben und
heute neben den Fähigkeiten zu Ersten
Hilfe zum Kampf zum Messer werfen kam
die Bereitschaft zum Kampf gegen den
Feind im Informationsbereich dazu
sie wolle der aserbaidschanischen
Propaganda etwas entgegensetzen sagt sie
den Feind mit allen Mitteln schlagen
ich sehe meine Zukunft so ich habe vier
Kinder drei Söhne und eine Tochter ich
sehe die Zukunft in meinem Land mein
Land ist Armenien und arzach
um die Region gibt es immer wieder
Kriege zuletzt vor zweieinhalb Jahren
erbittert brutal und mit tausenden Toten
auf beiden Seiten
[Musik]
laut UN gehört berkara Bach zu
Aserbaidschan aber es wohnen
mehrheitlich Arminia dort seitdem Krieg
2020 hat Aserbaidschan die Oberhand als
Verbindung zwischen Armenien und der
Karabach bleibt nur der schmale
latschinkorridor
das Armenia ungehindert nach
Bergkarabach und zurück können soll
eigentlich russisches Militär überwachen
doch im Dezember blockieren
Aserbaidschaner diesen Korridor und
Russland bleibt untätig
für die Armenia in Bergkarabach wird es
ein harter Winter
im Januar trifft unser Team heikoanian
er ist früh aufgestanden hofft noch
etwas zu essen zu bekommen aber er hat
kein Glück
es gibt hier drei Läden aber wie Sie
sehen können sind die geschlossen es
gibt kein Gemüse wir spüren die
Entbehrung sehr stark
120.000 Menschen sind in Bergkarabach
eingeschlossen darunter 30.000 Kinder
fast niemand kommt mehr raus oder rein
so wie Haix Frau ramella sie ist kurz
vor der Blockade nach Armenien gefahren
um ihre kranke Mutter zu versorgen und
sitzt nun dort fest ihren kleinen Sohn
sieht sie nur im Video kommen
Heike glaubt Aserbaidschan wolle die
Arminia in Bergkarabach aushungern sie
so aus der Region vertreiben
früher tausende Lastwagen aus Armenien
mit Lebensmitteln und anderen Produkten
jetzt kommen nur noch ganz selten
Konvois vom Roten Kreuz
sechs Wochen später darf Haix Frau mit
einem dieser Konvois zurückkommen
[Musik]
die Erleichterung ist groß aber werden
sie auf Dauer in Bergkarabach bleiben
können
im Juni treffen wir heik wieder er ist
auf dem Weg zum Friedhof hier liegt sein
Bruder begraben gefallen im letzten
Bergkarabach Krieg 2020
es gibt kaum ein Grab bei dem hike
unbeschwert vorbeigehen kann er kennt
viele der Soldaten die hier begraben
sind
auf jeder Seite gab es tausende Tote wie
soll man friedlich mit einem Volk
Zusammenleben dessen Regierung so eine
aggressive Politik verfolgt
ohne russische Hilfe hätten die Armenia
in der Karabach kaum eine Chance und zu
Aserbaidschan gehören das ist für Heike
keine Option
kommt haben wir keine andere Wahl wir
müssen zu den Waffen greifen ich glaube
nicht dass sie friedlich hierher kommen
werden es wird eine militärische
Aggression sein denn sie werden uns auf
jede erdenkliche Weise zerstören wollen
sowohl physisch als auch indem sie uns
von unserem Land vertreiben unsere
Geschichte zerstören und alle Spuren
unseres Aufenthalts hier
heikoft das nicht wieder Krieg ausbricht
dass seine Familie hier eine Zukunft hat
in ihrer Heimat so sehen Sie es
[Musik]
nur sieben Kilometer entfernt sieht man
das anders in diesem Teil bergkarabachs
hat Aserbaidschan wieder die Kontrolle
von schuscher kann man die verfeindeten
von Armenien bewohnten Städte gut sehen
die aserbaidschanische Armee hat
Zuschauer im Krieg 2020 zurückerobert
doch das soll erst der Anfang sein also
bei Jan will ganz bergabach unter seine
Kontrolle bringen
erst seit kurzem dürfen die also bei
Jana zurück die hier früher gewohnt
haben 30 Jahre ist es her
Sache zeigt uns die Ruinen seines
früheren Hauses
der Tag seiner Flucht hat für immer
Spuren hinterlassen
und die linke Hand wurde durch einen
weiteren verletzt direkt neben mir sind
zwei Menschen ums Leben gekommen
und in die aserbaidschanische Hauptstadt
Baku geflüchtet ist
es ist unmöglich zu sagen wie man sich
fühlt wenn man vor seinem eigenen Haus
steht
gar nicht da kann ich natürlich ich
werde das Haus mit meinen eigenen Händen
wieder aufbauen natürlich
amenia und Aserbaidschaner haben hier
lange zusammen gewohnt beide betrachten
Zuschauer als ihre Stadt immer wieder
haben sie darum gekämpft
[Musik]
der autokratische Präsident Ela Maria
lässt Zuschauer im Akkord wieder
aufbauen mit Geld das ihm das viele Öl
im Land einbringt
alias will hier seine Überlegenheit über
Armenien demonstrieren
regelmäßig zeigt er sich mit seiner
Ehefrau meriban alier war die
gleichzeitig Vizepräsidentin ist und er
nutzt den Ort für seine
nationalistischen Botschaften
war immer der Traum meines Vaters Haider
alias und alle Aserbaidschaner weltweit
wir haben uns diesen Traum erfüllt und
das aserbaidschanische Volk wird sich
immer an den Tag des Sieges am 8
November 2020 erinnern lang lebe das
aserbaidschanische Volk lang
Ende April schafft alliier Fakten und
baut am Eingang des Latschen
auf ein Bruch des
Waffenstillstandsabkommens von 2020 doch
der Autokrat fühlt sich im Recht
was die Kriege mit der Region gemacht
haben sehen wir im ehemaligen
Frontgebiet
wo früher Wein angebaut wurde sind jetzt
Minenfelder
Samir abasov sucht hier jeden Tag nach
Minen ein lebensgefährlicher Job für den
Familienvater aber dieses Risiko lächelt
er weg
selbst meine Kinder haben sich an die
ständige Bedrohung gewöhnt das Geräusch
einer Explosion ist für sie nichts
besonderes mehr es ist wie ein Donner
oder ein Gewitter
im Frühjahr mehrheitlich
aserbaidschanisch bewohnten akdam stehen
nur noch Ruinen
heute werfen sich beide Seiten die
gezielte Zerstörung ihrer Kulturgüter
vor
wie tief die Wunden sind erleben wir bei
Familie safarow Sarahs Sohn elmadin ist
im Krieg 2020 gefallen in Aserbaidschan
verehren sie die toten Soldaten als
Märtyrer
blieb 22 Tage lang auf den Feldern von
fiesoli liegen erst am 29 Oktober 2020
um 22 Uhr wurde uns mitgeteilt dass
unser Sohn gestorben ist
keine Mutter würde ihren Sohn so
verabschieden wollen
eltern sollten ihre Kinder nicht
begraben
ja
sarah safarova ist wütend auf die
Armenier sagt sie hätten ihr den Sohn
genommen
sie nehmen uns mit zum Friedhof zu Elmar
Dienst Grab
seit seinem Tod ist die Familie in der
ganzen Gegend bekannt
elmadin hat im Ort auf dem Schlachtfeld
Ehre gebracht so sehen Sie das hier
deswegen sagt seine Witwe Eichel das
auch ihr Sohn Soldat werden soll
natürlich wird er zum Soldaten
er soll wie jeder Mann ein Soldat sein
es ist seine Pflicht sein Heimatland zu
verteidigen
wie kann eine dauerhafte Aussöhnung
gelingen zwischen zwei Völkern die sich
seit Jahrzehnten hassen töten und
bekriegen
früher war Russland einflussreicher
Vermittler in der Region aber seit dem
ukrainekrieg hat Moskau diese Macht
nicht mehr
aserbaidschan hat inzwischen andere
mächtige Partner
auch in Europa
das Land verkauft sein Öl immer mehr
auch an westliche Demokratien
[Musik]
Kasachstan distanziert sich von Russland
will den Krieg gegen die Ukraine nicht
unterstützen das Land sucht Partner auch
unter moskausfeinden wer mehr Öl über
das Kaspische Meer nach Europa liefern
doch die Abhängigkeit von Russland ist
groß
wir reisen in den besten Kasachstans das
wirtschaftliche Herz des Landes hunderte
Pumpen holen im minutentaktöl aus der
Erde die Menschen sind auf den Export
angewiesen
man gehört damit zur Elite die
Bedingungen sind gut alle wollen
erdölarbeiter werden
der Leiter der Produktion erklärt uns
sie fördern Erdöl und Gas aber nur das
Öl werde ins Ausland geliefert
80% fließen durch russische Pipelines
Öl ist eine Lokomotive für die
Wirtschaft des ganzen Landes
aber in den vergangenen Jahren ist wegen
der Pandemie und anderen Einflüssen von
außen die Förderung gesunken
er nennt es nicht beim Namen aber
Russland blockierte mehrmals den Export
aus fadenscheinigen Gründen ein Zufall
glaubt kaum jemand in einer Zeit in der
sich Kasachstan von Moskau abwendet
die Einwohner der angrenzenden
Siedlungen sind gespalten wie sehr ihr
Land sich von Russland emanzipieren
sollte
außer Erdöl haben wir doch fast gar
nichts hier all die Arbeit alles hängt
vom Öl ab kannst du jetzt
wozu brauchen wir Russland wir sind
Kasachstan wir sind Kasachen das ist
unsere Heimat unser Öl
Moskau hat hier noch immer großen
Einfluss auf Wirtschaft und Politik
trotzdem lässt Kasachstan
hunderttausende Männer ins Land die
nicht für Russland sterben wollen
in der Millionenmetropole almati treffen
wir Alexander und seraphima sie sind
kurz vor Putins Teil mobil machen
geflohen haben in Russland alles
zurückgelassen denn Alexanders Schicksal
war längst besiedelt
[Musik]
sie brauchen dringend ein Bankkonto ihre
russischen Kreditkarten sind nutzlos
wegen der westlichen Sanktionen können
Sie nirgends bezahlen keine Wohnung
mieten keinen Job finden
es war sogar die Karte wurde sofort
gedruckt man muss nicht warten der
Bankautomat gibt sie gleich aus
ja so eine goldene Karte ist das
almati galt schon vor dem Krieg als
attraktiv für junge Menschen die das
verstaubte sowjet-image hinter sich
lassen wollen
[Musik]
eine Art meltingpott in dem jeder
willkommen ist
[Musik]
auch anastasia hat es deshalb hierher
verschlagen in den Hinterhöfen der Stadt
organisiert die Russin Hilfe für die
Ukraine zusammen mit Valentin einem
Ukrainer
als wir mit diesem Projekt anfingen habe
ich nur wenigen gesagt dass ich aus
Russland bin ich habe mich geschämt
es gibt viele Russen die hier helfen sie
unterstützen die Ukraine da ist mir egal
ob sie Russen oder nicht Russen sind
wenn ein Mensch anständig ist mache ich
keinen Unterschied
Anastasia verließ Russland schon vor
sieben Jahren
als dann 2022 die russische Armee in die
Ukraine einmarschierte wurde ihre Scham
Russin zu sein so groß dass sie
beschloss zu handeln
doch für ihre Flüchtlingshilfe bezahlt
sie einen hohen Preis
sogar
in meinem Land verändert werde ich nicht
dorthin zurückgehen denn ich habe Angst
ich habe einfach aus menschlicher Sicht
Angst ich bin 37
ich möchte nicht ins Gefängnis kommen
hier fühlt sie sich sicher und frei darf
gegen den Krieg sein
selbstbestimmt leben
Freiheiten die es in Russland längst
nicht mehr gibt
[Musik]
in Kirgisistan können sich putins-
das arme Land ist auf das Geld
moskausangewiesen
Menschenrechtsaktivistin julia kulesche
war musste das schmerzlich erfahren kurz
nach Kriegsbeginn verließ sie St
Petersburg mit ihrem Mann und ihrer
siebenjährigen Tochter
hier wollten sie sich ein neues Leben
aufbauen
3.500 Kilometer von ihrer Heimatstadt
entfernt denn Kirgisistan galt lange als
Insel der Demokratie
der after the world doch nach dem Krieg
kam es auch in Kirgisistan zu
Repressionen und sie haben versucht in
diesem Krieg Neutralität durchzusetzen
nicht nur für die Regierung sondern auch
für einzelne Menschen
das ist eine direkte Gefahr für die
Meinungsfreiheit denn als Einzelperson
kann ich nicht sagen dass ich gegen den
Krieg bin
Julia zeigt uns Ihr Haus in dem sie
viele Monate Veranstaltungen
organisierte für Exil Russen Kirgisen
Ukraine
bis zum 24 Februar dem Jahrestag des
Ukraine Kriegs als sie Blumen an einem
improvisierten Denkmal niederlegten und
festgenommen wurden
es war so skurril und gruselig als wir
dorthin kamen waren sie so ernst Männer
vom kirgisischen Geheimdienst die sagten
hören Sie sofort auf sie sind vom
Geheimdienst sie sind festgenommen
sie wird zwar am gleichen Tag
freigelassen aber fühlt sich seitdem
verfolgt es wirkt als würden die
Sicherheitsbehörden Russlands und
Kirgisistans zusammenarbeiten
julia und ihre Familie müssen sich wohl
bald wieder ein neues zu Hause suchen
[Musik]
wie eng Kirgisistan und Russland
verflochten sind erleben wir als wir in
die Berge fahren selbst hier auf 2500
Metern Höhe ist der Einfluss Moskau zu
spüren
[Musik]
Shiba cool und mukan wechseln sind
Nomaden
sie warten auf ihren Sohn
[Musik]
er hütet die Schafe denn nur hier oben
gibt es genug Weidefläche für sie ohne
die Tiere könnte die Familie nicht
überleben
[Musik]
als Sohn
fällt uns seine Jacke auf
Camouflage die russische Flagge
[Musik]
in Russland gearbeitet in Moskau ich bin
aber wieder zurückgekehrt unsere Jungs
gehen nach Moskau weil sie bei uns in
der Heimat keine Arbeit finden können
wir müssen Migranten werden
dass er eine russische Uniform trägt ist
für kovinic Speck kein Thema
eine Million arbeiten in Russland
Kirgisistan ist eines der ärmsten Länder
der Region
hier leben sie von der Hand in den Mund
covenic Speck hat sich in Russland nicht
wohl gefühlt der 25-Jährige wollte
zurück auf die J.Lo wie die Nomaden
liebevoll die hochweidenen doch er weiß
nicht wie lange er sich dieses Leben
noch leisten kann
[Musik]
zurück in der Hauptstadt wo sich
sowjetisches Erbe mit orientalischen
Einflüssen mischt auch gut 30 Jahre nach
dem Zusammenbruch der UdSSR ist
Kirgisistan abhängig von Russland
politisch wie wirtschaftlich
[Musik]
Gas und Öl kommen fast ausschließlich
aus Russland das nutzt Moskau um
Kirgisistan unter Druck zu setzen und an
sich zu binden
[Musik]
welche Folgen das hat sehen wir hier am
Rande der Stadt
um sich und ihre sieben Kinder zu
ernähren müssen er Mac und bactican rund
um die Uhr arbeiten sie stellen
traditionelle Teigtaschen her täglich
1000 Stück
sie machen sich große Sorgen um den
zweitältesten Sohn wächstan er hat in
Kirgisistan keinen Job gefunden und ist
nach Moskau ausgewandert dort arbeitet
er nun für einen Lieferservice
es ist ein schweres Leben er muss für
eine Wohnung bzw ein Zimmer bezahlen wo
sechs oder sieben Personen leben es ist
schwer dort zu schlafen er kann sich nie
ausruhen deshalb sind auch seine Kinder
unsere Enkel noch hier
sie laden uns zum Tee an das gebiete die
kirgisische Gastfreundschaft sagen sie
stolz auf ihre Traditionen
aber der lange Arm Russlands erreicht
selbst ihr Familienleben er Mac
wiederholt fast wörtlich die Propaganda
aus dem russischen Staatsfernsehen
in Bezug auf Russland auf die Politik
Putins da gebe ich mein GO er ist ein
echter Mann ich gucke jeden Tag diese
politische Talkshow er geht richtig vor
anfangs hatte ich nicht verstanden was
diese militärische sonderoperation soll
aber es stellte sich heraus dass
Russland gegen ganz Europa kämpfen muss
ich frage seine Frau wie es ihr damit
geht das Sohn bextan während des Kriegs
in Russland lebt dass er rekrutiert
werden könnte für die Front
ich mache mir natürlich Sorgen ich bin
doch seine Mutter
wieso redest du so dass du dir Sorgen
machst
ich sage ihm dass er ständig mit seinem
Pass unterwegs sein soll ich rufe ihn
drei bis viermal am Tag an trotzdem
man wird ihn doch nicht in die russische
Armee holen er arbeitet als Gastarbeiter
er ist ein Migrant
er hat damit nichts zu tun
vor der Armee schützen
doch Moskau nimmt auch zentralasiatische
Migranten immer stärker ins Visier sie
werden mit Geld in die russische Armee
gelockt
es ist die Armut die so viele Kirgisen
in die Arme Russlands treibt
auch für covinitschberg werden die
Einnahmen aus der Tierhaltung kaum
reichen spätestens wenn er seine eigene
Familie gründen will
[Musik]
in Zukunft werde ich vermutlich wieder
irgendwo hingehen
das hängt von den Umständen ab
es passiert hier so viel
ob er nicht nach Deutschland könne
fragen sie uns noch nicht ganz ernst
gemeint
denn hier wissen alle dass es vermutlich
nur eine echte Option geben wird
Russland
putinsplan war die ehemaligen
Sowjetrepubliken hinter sich zu
versammeln im Krieg gegen die Ukraine im
Kampf gegen den Westen ein russisches
Großreich wieder aufzubauen
stattdessen emanzipieren sich fast alle
Länder die wir bereist haben von Moskau
viele Menschen die wir kennengelernt
haben lehnen den Krieg gegen die Ukraine
ab
viele wollen in die EU
viele wollen einfach nur Frieden doch es
ist ein gefährlicher Spagat denn die
Macht Moskaus beeinflusst immer noch
Millionen und ihr Leben im Schatten
Russlands
[Musik]